typically they don't open the parliament
on fridays
but they're opening for this salmon
versus sturgeon round one one-time
friends
now big time enemies they'll give
evidence five days apart
in the burns room where all the
acquaintance will be forgot
it's been deep cleaned because of covet
it will get dirty
alex salmon will expand on his written
claims that his one-time protege
misled parliament and so broke the
ministerial code
and that party figures in her orbit
conspired to destroy his reputation
it's a story of betrayal and treachery
for msps on a hollywood committee asking
questions
there is a big question mark over
exactly what the first minister
knew and when she knew it and then how
the meetings that she
subsequently conducted with alex salmond
around those
investigations uh unraveled and how they
they were carried out whether she
adhered to all the rules that she must
follow as part of the ministerial code
an opinion poll for stv exhaust mori
shows support for the snp slipping
slightly
this inquiry is making some voters think
twice
although the snp is still on course for
a majority at may's parliamentary
elections
it feels very unsatisfactory it actually
feels
quite threatening to the sense of
democracy and fairness i'm very
impressed with how nicholas sturgeon has
been dealing with the covert situation
that's really what's important to me at
the moment
doubts have persisted over how far this
hollywood inquiry
can go in fulfilling its brief the
inquiry um
is in my view um either being starved of
information
or the problem is and it's the same in
some other committees
it's highly partisan all of the votes
are taken on party lines
and what we've got then is a lack of
trust the lack of respect
it's a kind of partisanship often uh
becoming tribalism
and that's not the way to handle a major
issue
such as this it's an episode this
parliament hasn't seen in its 22 years
two of the biggest names in scottish
political history
it took this country to the brink of
independence
where they take this contest is anyone's
game